if you want to contact us contact me
please feel free I am available 24/7
usually so if there's anything that will
come up from today that I really want to
point out over here is these two points
again because it's not an attack the
ammonia start with the technical aspect
which is kind of weird for me I really
want to focus on again a concept that I
have to deal with in the past two years
with individual across the data
community practice which is how do you
take all those individual knowledge base
in knowledge bytes that you have any one
of us over here really knowledgeable and
something very specific and we know some
other stuff and we all know how to
Google which is again I don't know what
we'll do with that Stack Overflow but
that's a whole other story but
regardless of that you know something
the person next to you know something
else but that's that that is very nice
that's very great but then comes the
problem when you actually have to apply
this when you actually have to take this
information and apply this to an actual
problem in the real world and that's
essentially what I'm going to touch on
which is how do you take all those
knowledge bites and how do you think
about this to actually delivering a
solution to a real problem that is end
to end so two points that I really want
to make over here so the first one is
when you're thinking about your problem
again and the problem I'm not defining
as I want to create a graph but rather I
want to create a decision tool for a
decision maker I want to make a decision
about where to go in an explication
whatever the range might be so the first
thing is your objective function you
really need to consider all the parts
and we'll touch this in a second really
need to touch about all the objectives
that within your when you're trying to
to end up as a value so that's the first
thing the second piece is think about
all those little bytes of information
that you know about how to do NLP and
how do you do for example word embedding
which is very very cool
in practice and we'll see an example in
a second but how do you take that and
not and actually apply what you take out
of the world in betting in order to
deliver a solution so these are the the
two elements that I really want to touch
on then well I really want to start with
a demo so like I said we're not gonna
show this live over here but okay can I
have the next slide please
all right and the next slide so what I
really want to go over here is let's say
you have an application over here and
this is a just ever presentation this is
a shiny dashboard and you really want to
take a end-to-end solution so what that
looks like can I have the next slide
please
so essentially what this tool does if I
later on if you want to go in the back
in the table I can show you this live is
to take it call customer service call
and really make a decision about the
probability of whatever you want to
apply to that particular call
and I think call center think any end
over here in the end to end of a of an
audio file so you have essentially
multiple component over here the ends
end result is how do I make a decision
and in order to do this you're really
breaking it down backwards to your
elements over here so what you have over
here is essentially the ability to
upload the uploaded file in audio file
how do you process audio file by the way
last week audio processing book with a
are came out an excellent book really
highly recommending that but you have an
API call so we have an API calls to
Google over here we have transcription
we have deep neural network and we have
the audio representation and as you can
see at the bottom left we have a
probability we have topic all of this
really putting together so this is
essentially a representation of an
element's that that kind of is this kind
of a solution this kind of thinking will
deliver so you have you know how to do
an API call for example but how do you
connect that to an actual decision and
now I have a text I can take the text I
can work with an audio next slide please
and you have the sentiment over here and
I'm not gonna dive into this so much but
you can see that now you can make a
decision about a particular call
so this taking into account let's move
to the next slide and really gonna talk
about how this has worked so in practice
your model and I'm sure we all know
elements of this one is really just any
machine learning any code base is really
a small element in your infant in your
entire architecture of your of your
solution it's not really gonna be the
main thing per se I read someplace it's
roughly about 5% of actual solution is
actually your machine learning code
it's it's really a how do you consider
the different elements of the operation
how do you consider the different
elements of the graphical representation
the user interface you need to take into
account so you have machine learning how
do you take the machine learning and
connect that to your to your user
interface so the user can actually do
something about that so that's where
your objective function comes into play
and this is really the main point over
here and I really want you to think
about when you approach a solution your
machine learning piece or your code base
over here is really it's a portion of it
and you need to address with a
capability preferably an hour that will
a that will address the different
elements over here so you have to
consider the input you have to think
about what data you have available how
do you generate that how do you access
that how user will access that
information and that is through variety
of packages variety of capability that
you might have in the in your tool you
have to think about the cost elements of
this one so I'm talking about
computational power I'm talking about a
architecture how much it's gonna cost
you across the user and is it worth it
so think about the return on your
investment over here
and like I said the the the cost also
comes as a human cost like how much time
and effort this will take your process
really takes into account the how much
interaction you need so in the demo just
in the in the slide that I just showed
your interaction is just one button
again in the back you will actually be
able to see this live you
just upload the or the audio file you
upload the audio file we will do the
this tool itself does the audio
processing it does the API call it does
the NOP capability over there to make
decision the machine learning around on
top of that all that is happening in the
back end the user doesn't care so that's
important to us for you for you to know
when you're developing this tool and
then again it's really about what the
business problem is and that's really
really where I spend a lot of my time
and a lot of the teams that we running
really need to take the problem and
convert it to a business problem which
is what is really the objective that
you're trying to do you're trying to
make a decision or you're trying to
impact the operation and every piece
over here will impact what you're
actually going to do with this
particular tool I want to end to point
over here that the value really where's
the value of your tool so if you have a
nice graph you have a nice analysis you
have you did your statistics that is
that is important that is important to
the decision but it's a one-time one
thing is it solving the problem on a
continuous basis is it an end-to-end
solution or the next month when you have
to do it again or somebody else has to
do it again then how do you actually
approach that how do you actually
implement that so I want you so each
elements over here in this same in this
a objective function really need to
enter into account every every element
needs to take the capability by itself
and that is essentially where you apply
your different knowledge and work as a
team so let's move on to the next slide
real second and this is how we actually
think about this this I'm really
starting with the problem really looking
at the business a question and really
how do you decompose the business
question and it's not only a data
science exercise it's really around the
different elements that goes into the
solution do they really care about
seeing the data if they don't care then
you don't show it but if they do you do
where's the data coming from do I need
to apply any sort of web scraping or the
data is
labeled and nicely organized so that's
something in the main point in this
slide is the the point in the middle
over here you solve a problem not all at
once you can assume and this is this is
something that I've talked a lot to aim
different leaders with an organization
which is I can make the assumption
because of all of you over here and
because the other developers out there I
can make an assumption that when I look
at it as a kind of a LEGO pieces so I
have it I have a problem on the right
end and I want to get to a solution I
can assume that ok I need to do X I need
to do y I need to do Z and each one of
those somebody has a deep neural deep
knowledge of that one and solve that or
to a degree and then I can apply that
capability and then comes the problem
how do I actually connect those those
capability but I would assume that those
capabilities exist so that's a that is a
and then we do a step approach over here
so if we go to the next slide and it's
really where I want to take this and
really show this to a practical example
and and really how did we take this
approach of really solving one problem
at a time and assuming that the
capability exists and assuming that this
capability can interact with each other
and really talk to past information from
a capability to a capability so if we go
to the next slide I'm gonna go through
the architecture over here and you can
see that each element over here I'm
using different capabilities different
packages different information that will
feed into that so we need the problem
statement over here is how do I find
information how do I find a particular
piece of text in a really large pile of
text that and again I'm not this NLP
discussion later on I'm not gonna go
into that but how do I go and find
information in this pile of text that I
know that exists out there in order it
but by my query
so it's essentially information
retrieval problems so how do we go this
is I I break it into the component
capability so the first thing is you
take the oil you take where's the data
so if you remember from the objective
function
I took their own we took online data we
really scraped that so there are there
are different packages and different
capability to do that okay I have all
this information a lot of PDFs I need to
OCR this information and really connect
those in connect this information into a
in one location do the data cleanup
again not NLP discussion but I know now
I have a bunch of clean texts I need to
detect elements of a elements of this of
an information so for example entity so
there are capability like coronel p m or
an API call to a other services for
example google that will provide that
and so i need to build an api a
connection to to google once i have all
of that i can start building word
embedding and that's in other
classification capabilities and again
for this one there's a word vector is
one of the ones that we use and the idea
is okay now I have I have the connection
of the I know and enough about those
words I can then link that to a
particular data a data bank that we can
we need to create because the user
doesn't want doesn't care for lack of a
better term where is this data they
assuming it's just out there and then
from there I need to create the a user
interface a connection point so again we
use shiny and other capabilities as you
link that and what you get is
essentially we think about Anna data
science like the picture that you see at
the bottom which is I take every token
and I have information about this token
so for example the term Watts voltaren
is a request for information it's really
related to a will I know that the term
post doesn't mean a post it means a
location etc and and so we're thinking
about this in in this kind of term okay
a nice little table a part of speech I
know what they related to I know what
the connection is post is related to a
to a special agent etc but that's really
cool okay I solved the problem of a
a table you lysing my information and
now I have all this but the user doesn't
care like this is very can I have the
next slide please
the user doesn't care so what we
developed what III want to present again
taking this concept into account is you
taking this query and it's information
that that receive and you can all see
are it okay you did all see are now what
now the OCR takes into account that the
fact that our question can we identified
question etc and all this needs to
happen seamlessly because you took into
account in the objective function that
the user the value to the users that
it's going to be simple and they don't
really care what's happening behind the
scenes so we care about the table from
the last slide but in reality okay we
have the question we identify the
question we submit the question can I
have the next slide please and what
happens in the back end is that we
created the semantic link so the point
that I'm trying to make is that and
again I wish I could show this live go
to the back else or later on in the
break this movie life but the idea over
here is that taking that word embedding
for example and identifying what the
relationship of award to award is or
taking your a ordinate a synonyms
capability and taking all that this is
really cool by itself but putting it
together to say okay this is like this
that's what the objective function gave
me and that's what I'm really presenting
out to the user and that's is
essentially what what happens over there
it when it found that the user see a CA
one piece of information and they can
upload downloads
that's really where where it's a it's
there they use a decision so again as
you think through your problem the the
data elements over here are very
interesting but it's really matter how
you really delivering value at the end
so let's move to the next slide um so
what I really want to keep you in what I
want individuals to keep in mind and
really what I found and this is again a
concept that I have to deal with on a
daily basis which is how do you deliver
a solution and not just an interesting
capability and the answer is connecting
different people
this together and to deliver an
end-to-end and we have those
capabilities running through this data
science community so I encourage
everybody to consider the value of the
different option that you add into your
tool to your capability and and and it
really should be it should be easy to
explain what you do and it really should
be very easy to deliver that a user
should be able to enter new information
into your system into your tool if it's
not easy and it's just the data and then
it's a data science exercise and and
really the the main point over here is
that it you need to eat like I said
before develop one thing at a time not
all at once different pilot sections one
thing at a time and assume you can
assume that different components exist
to make that Lego visual ready for you
when you're done
[Applause]